dan Simon's and I were teaching a course
at Harvard University on research
methods in the psychology department
this is a course where students have to
design their own psychology research
projects and carry them out and as part
of the course we also thought it would
be a good idea to have some group
projects that everyone could participate
in dan had the idea to look at some work
that had been done in the 1970s a
somewhat famous experiment by Ulrich and
iczer one of the pioneers of cognitive
psychology who had some people sort of
play basketball passing balls around on
an empty basketball court and managed to
get the groups of people to overlap by
filming the most special mirrors and
then while people are watching these
basketball players they're supposed to
count the number of times the ball gets
passed about halfway through the video a
woman carrying an umbrella walks through
the basketball court the surprising
finding of his experiment was that many
people who were counting the basketball
passes didn't see the woman with the
umbrella walking through and didn't
remember her being there at all this
funny thing about the experiment though
was that since it was film using the
special technique with mirrors everyone
was sort of invisible and transparent
and you could see through them it was
very unusual looking display it's the
kind of thing that nowadays you would do
with digital video editing back in the
1970s he used mirrors some people had
sort of dismissed the finding that
people missed this very obvious and
salient thing like a woman walking
through a basketball game because it was
a strange-looking visual display so we
decided to try to do a new version of
this experiment where all the action was
live and we had six people passing
basketballs around sort of choreograph
to not run into each other and to not
throw the ball in each other's face and
so on and that was a bit of a challenge
and setting up this experiment but
that's what we have students in the
course for we managed to get it right
and then we had a woman walk through
carrying an umbrella just like nicer did
what was a little more amusing for us
though was that one of the other
professors in the department happened to
have a gorilla suit lying around in his
lab and we thought it would be fun to
have someone walk through wearing the
gorilla suit and see whether that was
noticed and we had first thought that
people would notice the gorilla walking
through the basketball game because
there's no longer this sort of
transparent see-through display and the
gorilla actually stayed on the screen
for nine full seconds and one of the
versions of our video when we ran the
experiment and our students went out and
tested people on the Harvard campus we
found that about half of the people did
not at all notice the gorillas and in
fact were very surprised they hadn't
noticed the gorillas there were actually
sort of two findings from this
experiment one you can miss very salient
things like a gorilla walking right in
front of you and two that you're shocked
that you could miss it most people seem
to have the intuitive idea that they're
going to see this kind of thing and
they're really surprised when they find
out that they don't
but this experiment shows is that when
we're paying attention to something
basically doing a task that demands our
attention such as counting the passes of
the basketball in this case or really
any other kind of really attention
demanding task that we do we can
seriously overestimate our ability to do
other tasks at the same time and
especially to notice and handle
unexpected or surprising things we think
that we're going to notice unexpected
things that come into our field of view
and we think we're going to pay
attention to the things we should pay
attention to but in fact when we're
focused on one task we're noticing and
paying attention to a lot less than we
really think
this experiment implies a lot about our
behavior in everyday life for example
when we are driving and talking on a
cell phone at the same time we get the
feeling that we're actually driving just
as well as when we're not talking on the
phone that's part of why we do things
like talking on the phone while we're
driving or even sent text messages or
read our email which are actually much
worse but even talking on the phone
while driving depletes a lot of your
attention talking on the phone while
you're driving is like counting the
basketball passes in our experiment you
can still drive but what you're gonna
have a problem with is noticing
unexpected things and when you think
about it those are the really important
things to notice when you're driving
it's one thing to just drive down an
open highway at night it's another thing
to drive in the suburbs when someone
might be pulling out of their driveway
right in front of you or someone might
be stopping short right in front of you
and you want to have the reaction time
to be able to stop and not crash into
them or even worse someone pushes a baby
stroller out in front of the in front of
the road so we're actually a lot worse
at that than we think we are and we
should in fact put down the cell phone
while we're driving and perhaps even zip
it up in a briefcase or a purse or
something like that those are some of
the implications for everyday life but
it's not just driving there are many
other situations like this for example
the security screeners at airports we
sort of have the impression that they're
paying attention to everything that's in
our suitcase and our luggage and so on
but actually everybody has sort of an
inflated impression of how much they're
paying attention to and we may not be as
safe as we think we are even with you
know trained and dedicated people doing
that lifeguards at swimming pools
radiologists looking at medical scans
for anomalies and so on
when you're looking for one thing or
paying attention to one thing it's easy
to not notice other things and to not
realize that you're not noticing those
things
a TV news magazine that covered our
research actually recreated the
experiment for themselves in their own
studios and they had a bunch of
volunteers come in and look at the
videotape and count the passes and and
mr. gorilla and they filmed the
reactions of some of them and my
favorite one of all was someone who said
that bear didn't go through there did it
did you notice that what I'm wearing
actually changed several times during
the course of this interview some people
might have noticed some of the changes
but it's probably unusual to notice all
of those changes